sie ist nach angaben der nasa nicht nur
die höchste sondern auch die
leistungsstärkste rakete der geschichte
space launch system sls ist 20
stockwerke hoch und achtung bis zu
28.000 400 kilometer pro stunde schnell
die super g wurde jetzt offiziell von
der nasa präsentiert 2024 soll sie dann
die erste frau und den nächsten mann auf
den mond bringen klick substanzen
fiction gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocken und dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen nasa chef jim briten stein
sprach bei der offiziellen vorstellung
der super-g space launch system sls von
einem sehr wichtigen tag für die
weltraumbehörde demnach sei die
entwicklung und fertigstellung ein zitat
wichtiger meilenstein und ein beweis für
das amerikanische unternehmertum und den
erfindergeist mit mehr als 1.000 einer
großen und kleinen unternehmen in 44
staaten die ihr zur konstruktion und
montage beitragen wird die sls rakete
amerika befähigen das ziel des artemis
programms zu erreichen die erste frau
und den nächsten mann bis 2024 auf dem
mond zu landen den bemannten flug zum
mond steht quasi nichts mehr im wege
2020 soll der orangefarbene gigant das
erste mal getestet werden und 2021
sollen sie ein orion raumschiff um den
mond transportieren allerdings unbemannt
ein bemannter staat könnte und 2022
erwarten für das jahr 2024 ist dann der
große coup der nasa geplant mehr als 51
jahre nach der letzten mondlandung soll
dann also auch eine frau teil der
besatzung seien eine echte premiere die
nasa möchte sich am südpol des mondes
vor allem mit dem wasser eis
beschäftigen dass dort in der
vergangenheit aufgespürt werden konnte
im besten fall könnte es in sauerstoff
und wasserstoff aufgespalten werden
wichtig zum einen als treibstoff für die
rakete und zum anderen um trinkwasser zu
gewinnen dazu dem bindend sein
wir wollen lernen wie wir in einer
anderen welt leben und arbeiten können
65 meter hoch und damit so groß wie an
20 stöckiges gebäude ist diese pakete
space launch system
doch nicht nur das ist ein rekord auch
ihre leistung übertrifft alles nach
offiziellen nasa-angaben erreicht sie
eine rekord über
geschwindigkeit von mach 23 also 23
fache schallgeschwindigkeit umgerechnet
sind das 28 tausend kilometer pro stunde
diese geschwindigkeit sollen sie
erreichen wie sie dann von der orion
mannschafts kapsel getrennt wird neben
einer mondlandung sollen außerdem die
ersten bauteile einer lunaren
raumstation in den mond orbit gebracht
werden fachleute sprechen von einem
jahren gateway dies könnte für
mondlandungen in der zukunft als basis
und als zwischenstation dient das ganze
projekt wird vor allem von der us
regierung um präsident donald trump nach
vorne getrieben die kosten liegen
mittlerweile bei 8 milliarden dollar
anfangs waren lediglich 6,2 milliarden
dollar geplant ist ja immer noch nicht
so ganz sicher ob das hinten und vorne
überhaupt reich geprägt war die
entwicklung der riesen rakete bislang
von zeitlichen verzögerungen und
kostenüberschreitungen ursprünglich
sollte der test auch schon im november
2018 stattfinden der raketenstart gehört
mit zur artemis tim missionen der nasa
benannt nach der mondgöttin und
zwillingsschwester napoleons aus der
griechischen mythologie eine anlehnung
also an die apollo-mission die usa sehen
den bemannten flug zum mond auch als
einen test für eine bemannte
mars-mission angedacht ist diese für die
2030er jahre und die usa haben es
wirklich sehr eilig denn derzeit haben
die amerikaner keinerlei möglichkeiten
selbst ins all oder zwei ss zu gelang
stattdessen sind sie auf russland und
dessen sojus kapseln und raketen
angewiesen und das bereits seit dem ende
der space shuttle im jahr 2011 schon
2009 10 wurde die super kind zum test
centern verschifft dazu nasa chef jim
münster betrachten sie es als nasers
weihnachtsgeschenk für amerika cool aber
nicht alles klappt im moment bei der
nasa erst vor wenigen tagen hat eine
starliner kapsel von boeing
die iss die internationale raumstation
nicht erreicht weil es was als
fehlschlag gilt und anfang 2009 10 ist
ja eine space extraction kapsel im april
explodiert all das wirft die ambitionen
der nasa immer wieder zurück und macht
das projekt teurer space extremfälle
exponierte dragon zerstörung und schlag
für die bemannte raumfahrt anklicken
anschauen und klicks um science-fiction
unbedingt abonnieren dann verpasste
nämlich kein video mehr biss dann bleibt
dran